Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. At New Balance, we believe if you run, you're a a runner however you choose to do it because when you're not worried about doing things the right way you're free to discover your way and that's what running's all about
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。New Balance 认为，只要你跑步，你就是跑者，无论你以何种方式前行。因为当你不再担心是否用“正确”的方式跑步时，你便能自由探索属于自己的风格，这正是跑步的真谛。
run your way at newbalance.com slash running. Near the end of the last ice age, 12,800 years ago, a giant comet that had entered the solar system from deep space thousands of years earlier broke into multiple fragments. Some of these struck the Earth, causing a global cataclysm on a scale unseen since the extinction of the dinosaurs, and causing the global deluge that is remembered in myths all around the world. A second series of impacts, equally devastating, causing further cataclysmic flooding, occurred 11,600 years ago, the exact date that Plato gives for the destruction and submergence of Atlantis. The evidence shows beyond reasonable doubt that an advanced civilization that flourished during the Ice Age was destroyed in these global cataclysms. But there were survivors, known to later cultures as the sages, the magicians, the shining ones,
在 newbalance.com 寻找你的跑步方式。在上一冰河时代末期的 12,800 年前，一颗巨型彗星在数千年前从深空进入太阳系后分裂成多块碎片。其中一些撞击了地球，引发了自恐龙灭绝以来前所未见的全球大灾难，并导致了世界各地神话中流传的全球大洪水。第二轮同样具有毁灭性的撞击引发了更具灾难性的洪水，发生在 11,600 年前，这正是柏拉图给出的亚特兰蒂斯毁灭和沉没的确切日期。证据无可辩驳地表明，冰河时代繁荣的高度文明在这些全球大灾难中被毁了。但有一些幸存者，后世文化称他们为智者、魔术师、发光者，
and the mystery teachers of heaven. They traveled the world in their great ships, doing all in their power to keep the spark of civilisation burning. They settled at key locations – Gobekli Tepe in Turkey, Baalbek in the Lebanon, Giza in Egypt, ancient Sumer, Mexico, Peru, and across the Pacific, where a huge pyramid has recently been discovered in Indonesia. Everywhere they went, these magicians of the gods brought with them the memory of a time when mankind had fallen out of harmony with the universe and paid a heavy price. So that, Tom Holland, is the synopsis of the book Magicians of the Gods
以及天堂的神秘导师。他们乘着大船游历世界，竭尽全力让文明的火种燃烧。他们在关键地点定居——土耳其的哥贝克力石阵、黎巴嫩的巴勒贝克、埃及的吉萨、古代苏美尔、墨西哥、秘鲁，以及横跨太平洋的印尼，最近那里刚刚发现了一座巨大的金字塔。无论走到哪里，这些神的魔术师都带来了对一个时期的记忆：那时人类曾与宇宙失去和谐并付出了沉重的代价。汤姆·霍兰，这就是《神明魔术师》一书的梗概，
from the website of the renowned historian Graham Hancock. And it's also the premise for his Netflix series, Ancient Apocalypse, of which I believe you are an enormous fan. Well, I've watched all 10 episodes. Whether that equates to fandom or whether yeah i was doing it as research for the episode dominate that we're doing actually two episodes on atlantis where does the story come from is it true was there really an ancient apocalypse that wiped an ancient civilization out these are the hefty questions that we'll be exploring over the next two episodes well people love these questions tom that's why ancient why Ancient Apocalypse is so popular. Of course, it's not an entirely uncontroversial series or an uncontroversial thesis.
摘自著名历史学家格雷厄姆·汉考克的网站。这也是他的网飞系列纪录片《远古 apocalypse》（远古启示录）的前提，我相信你是该片的超级粉丝。好吧，我看完了全部 10 集。这算不算是粉丝，还是说我其实是在为我们正在制作的关于亚特兰蒂斯的节目做资料搜集呢？我们实际上做了两集关于亚特兰蒂斯的节目：这个故事从何而来？它是真的吗？真的曾有远古启示录摧毁了一个古代文明吗？这些都是我们在接下来两集里将要探讨的沉重问题。人们就是喜欢这些问题，汤姆，这就是为什么《远古启示录》会如此受欢迎。当然，这并不是一个完全没有争议的系列，也不是一个没有争议的论点。
But even as a boy, I remember these sort of books of mysteries, historical mysteries, the Osborne books. And Atlantis was always huge in those. I remember when Doctor Who went to Atlantisantis twice professor zaroff was using atlantis as an underwater base did you ever see warlords of atlantis uh don't think so it was doug mcclure who was always um he was always kind of going off on boats and ending up in lands that time forgot or kind of things like that um and warlords of Atlantis, he discovers that Atlantis is true. And it's an underwater kind of realm. So there was a brilliant series that the BBC repeated in the 80s called Undersea Kingdom.
但即使作为一个男孩，我也记得这类神秘书籍，历史神秘书籍，奥斯本丛书。亚特兰蒂斯在其中总是占有巨大分量。我记得《神秘博士》曾两次去过亚特兰蒂斯——扎罗夫教授把亚特兰蒂斯用作水下基地。你见过《亚特兰蒂斯的霸主》吗？呃，好像没有。那是道格·麦克卢尔，他总是……他总是乘着船到处跑，最后到了被时间遗忘的土地或是类似的地方。在《亚特兰蒂斯的霸主》中，他发现亚特兰蒂斯是真的，那是一个水下王国。BBC在 80 年代重播过一部精彩的电视剧，叫《海底王国》。
It was from the 1930s, American. The star was supposedly Crash Corrigan, who was a sort of Flash Gordon ripoff. And they went to Atlantis. And Atlantis was amazing. They had tanks. They had tanks called juggernauts. It was very exciting. Because all that ultimately comes from Jules Verne.
那是 20 世纪 30 年代的美国作品。主演据说是克拉什·科里根，有点像《飞侠哥顿》的翻版。他们去了亚特兰蒂斯，那里的亚特兰蒂斯太惊人了。他们有坦克，被称为“巨无霸”的坦克。这非常令人兴奋。因为这一切最终都源自儒勒·凡尔纳。
Yeah. And they go around, you know, in Captain Nemo in his submarine going around. But also, Tom, it's the story of the new Rings of Power series, because that's about the fall of Numenor. Yes, it is. Yes. Tolkien was obsessed by the story.
对。他们四处游历，你知道，尼莫船长乘着他的潜艇到处走。但是，汤姆，这也是《力量之戒》新系列的故事，因为那是关于努门诺尔的陨落。是的，确实如此。托尔金对这个故事着迷不已。
Yeah. So in Numenor, it's hubris, challenging the gods, all of that stuff that brings... This is a spoiler for people who are intending to watch all 27 series of The Rings of Power when they finally make them. I mean, that's part of the fascination, isn't it? It's not just an undersea kingdom. It is the fact that it is the ultimate punishment for human arrogance. Well, the idea that it is an undersea kingdom i mean it begins with jules verne there's no hint of that before i mean you know right and a kingdom plunges into the sea which is what the story says everyone drowns i mean yeah it's not
是的，在努门诺尔，这是傲慢，是对诸神的挑战，所有这些东西带来了……这是对那些打算看完整整 27 季《力量之戒》（如果他们最终真能拍出来的话）的人的剧透。我的意思是，这正是魅力的一部分，不是吗？它不仅仅是一个海底王国，而是它是对人类傲慢的终极惩罚。关于它是一个海底王国的想法，我的意思是，它始于儒勒·凡尔纳，此前没有任何迹象表明这一点。我的意思是，你知道的，对吧？一个王国坠入大海，这就是故事所说的，所有人都淹死了。我的意思是，是的，并不是
like people survive not in the versions i've seen tom patrick duffy he was the man from atlantis all that kind of stuff yeah right um so i think that's much more a thing that's um yeah you know uh tv series and dramas and things like that science fiction but as graham hancock said in his introduction the the evidence that atlantis or a version of atlantis actually existed he says has been proved beyond reasonable doubt yes so that is a claim that i think deserves some stress testing. And it kind of begs the question, well, where does the whole idea of Atlantis come from? And you know the answer, don't you?
像有人幸存下来一样，至少在我看过的版本里不是这样，汤姆。帕特里克·达菲，他是《亚特兰蒂斯人》里的那个男主角，诸如此类的东西，对吧，嗯。所以我觉得这更像是那种……嗯，你知道的，电视剧、戏剧之类的东西，科幻小说。但正如格雷厄姆·汉考克在他的引言中所说，亚特兰蒂斯或某种版本的亚特兰蒂斯实际存在的证据，他说已经被证明是“无可辩驳的”。是的，所以这是一个我认为值得进行压力测试的主张。这引发了一个问题：亚特兰蒂斯这个概念究竟从何而来？你知道答案，对吧？
I do know the answer. Brilliant. Fortunately. That's great news. The podcast will be continuing beyond the five minutes that we're spending. So the thing about Atlantis, unlike say the Trojan War or the story of Exodus or King Arthur, is that we can pinpoint very precisely where the story begins. So Geoffrey of Monmouth writing about King Arthur, there's a whole kind of tradition before him. Exodus or the Iliad, scholars have been able to trace the fact that this isn't the first version of it, that it's a recycling of earlier versions. But with Atlantis, we know exactly who
我确实知道答案。太棒了。幸好如此。这真是个好消息。这个播客将继续进行下去，而不仅仅是我们花的那五分钟。关于亚特兰蒂斯的奇妙之处在于，与特洛伊战争、出埃及记或亚瑟王的故事不同，我们可以非常准确地指出这个故事是从哪里开始的。因此，杰弗里·莫茅斯撰写关于亚瑟王的作品时，他之前已经有一整套传统了；对于出埃及记或《伊利亚特》，学者们已经能够追溯到这并不是它的第一个版本，而是早期版本的重新加工。但对于亚特兰蒂斯，我们确切地知道谁
is the first person to discuss it. And it is the great philosopher Plato, who in two of his dialogues writes about, hey, Atlantis Nessos, kind of the island of Atlantis, but it also could mean the island of Atlas. He's the first king of this great island. Is he the fellow who had the world and not different Atlas? No, so that's Atlas Mountains, the idea that Atlas is a titan who is holding up the cosmos on his shoulders. This is a different Atlas who is supposedly the son of Poseidon,
是第一个讨论它的人。那就是伟大的哲学家柏拉图，他在他的两篇对话录中写到了“Atlantis Nesos”，也就是亚特兰蒂斯岛，但这也可以意味着阿特拉斯岛。他是这个伟大岛屿的第一任国王。他是那个背负世界而不是不同阿特拉斯的家伙吗？不，那是阿特拉斯山脉，人们认为阿特拉斯是一个双肩扛着宇宙的泰坦。这是一个不同的阿特拉斯，据说是海神兼地震之神波塞冬的儿子，
who is the god of the sea and of earthquakes. So would obviously play an outsized role in the disaster that ultimately overwhelms Atlantis. And the basic story is that there was an island beyond the pillars of Hercules, so the Straits of Gibraltar, out in the Atlantic. It's very, very successful. And then it gets plunged under the waters of the ocean. But I think that before we go into the detail of exactly what Plato says about it, it would be worth looking at Plato himself. Do you think what he says is very much a reflection of his own
因此，他在最终吞没亚特兰蒂斯的大灾难中显然会扮演举足轻重的角色。基本的故事是，在海格力斯之柱（即直布罗陀海峡）之外的宏大岛屿上，大西洋中有一个亚特兰蒂斯。它非常非常成功。然后它沉入了海洋的水面之下。但我觉得在我们深入探讨柏拉图对其具体说法的细节之前，先来看看柏拉图本人是值得的。你认为他的言论很大程度上反映了他自己的
background and interests and his own political predilections, Dean? Is that a big spoiler? Well, I think that since we know that there is no evidence of this story having existed before Plato, there's not a hint of it. No one mentions Atlantis before Plato. No one even kind of alludes to a story that might be kind of mistaken for Atlantis before Plato. Therefore, it's worth looking at his life to see if the story is true, how might he have come by it? If the story isn't true, how come he's writing about it? And actually, I think that people might be tempted to think that Atlantis is just a bit of fun. It's kind of fluff. It's kind of mad story. But actually, I think it holds a really, really fascinating mirror up, not just to Plato, who was a British philosopher who said that, I think,
背景、兴趣以及他自己的政治偏好吗，迪安？这是一个大剧透吗？嗯，我认为既然我们知道没有证据表明这个故事在柏拉图之前存在过，甚至连一点迹象都没有。在柏拉图之前没有人提到过亚特兰蒂斯。甚至没有人暗示过一个可能被误认为是亚特兰蒂斯的故事。因此，值得审视他的人生：如果这个故事是真的，他是如何得知的？如果这个故事不是真的，他为什么要在写它？实际上，我认为人们可能会倾向于认为亚特兰蒂斯只是一件好玩的事，有点像泡沫，有点疯狂的故事。但实际上，我认为它不仅向柏拉图投射了一面非常非常迷人的镜子——曾有一位英国哲学家说过，我想，
something to the effect that the whole of Western philosophy is merely a series of footnotes to Plato. He was Athenian. There are some who say that he was born on Aegina, which is an island kind of just off Attica, but whatever. He is an Athenian citizen. He's born in the 420s and he dies around either 348 or 347. His name Plato, that's a nickname. It kind of means broad-shouldered, broad-chested. The story goes that he's given this nickname by his wrestling tutor. There are worse nicknames to have. It's brilliant, isn't it? a wrestling tutor um it's probable that his actual name was aristocles but uh again can't be certain i mean it won't surprise you to know that
大意是整个西方哲学只不过是对柏拉图的一系列脚注。他是雅典人。有人说他出生在埃伊纳岛，那是一个紧邻阿提卡的小岛，但不管怎样。他是雅典公民。他出生于公元前 420 年代，死于公元前 348 或 347 年左右。他的名字柏拉图，那是个绰号。大致意思是肩宽、胸宽。故事说，他的摔跤教练给了他这个绰号。还有比这更糟糕的绰号。这太棒了，不是吗？摔跤教练……他的本名很可能是阿里斯托克利斯，但同样，无法确定。我的意思是，你不会感到惊讶地知道
there are lots of details about plato's life we don't know that yeah it's lucky that he was nicknamed plato because had he been called aristocles i mean imagine students coping with him and aristotle be awful wouldn't, wouldn't it? Terribly confusing. Yes. So Plato is from an aristocratic family that can trace their line of descent back to the kings of Athens who ruled way back in the mists of time and ultimately all the way back to Poseidon, actually, as it happens. So the god of the sea. That's nice. They're a very politically active family, and they are active in a way that because they're aristocratic, but they are also politically active in Athens, which has become a democracy. They, as a family, kind of straddle the ambivalences and the complexities that are thrown up by the fact that Athens is a society that has an aristocracy,
关于柏拉图生平的很多细节我们都不知道。幸运的是他被叫作柏拉图，因为如果他叫阿里斯托克利斯——想象一下学生们应付他和亚里士多德的情形，那不是太糟糕了吗？非常混乱。是的。所以柏拉图出身于一个贵族家庭，其家谱可以追溯到湮没在历史迷雾中的雅典国王，巧合的是，最终一直追溯到海神波塞冬。也就是海神。这很好。这是一个政治上非常活跃的家庭，他们的活跃方式在于，由于他们是贵族，同时他们也在雅典积极参与政治，而雅典已经成为一个民主制国家。作为一个家族，他们横跨了由于雅典是一个既有贵族阶层，
but is also very radically democratic. So there are all kinds of tensions there. And he's born into a city that is one of the two great cities of Greece. So there is Sparta, which is a kind of military state. We did an episode on Sparta, very much a kind of warrior city, military. The whole citizenship are devoted to training, military training and all that kind of stuff. Athens is a much more cosmopolitan place, but the Athenians too value the kind of the courage and the bravery that is shown by infantrymen. And the great, decisive, kind of glorious, epic memory that Athenians in when Plato is born is the Battle of Marathon. When a Persian army in 490 BC crosses the sea, lands on the plain of Marathon, about 25 miles from Athens, and the Persians have never been beaten by a Greek army.
又有着非常激进的民主制的社会所带来的矛盾和复杂性。所以这里面存在着各种各样的张力。他出生在一座城市里，这座城市是希腊两大伟大城市之一。其中一个是斯巴达，这是一个某种军事国家。我们做过一期关于斯巴达的节目，它非常像一个勇士城市、军事城市。全体公民都致力于训练、军事训练以及诸如此类的事情。雅典是一个更加国际化的地带，但雅典人同样珍视步兵表现出的勇气和英勇。在柏拉图出生时，雅典人心中那个伟大、决定性、辉煌、史诗般的记忆就是马拉松战役。公元前 490 年，波斯军队渡海，在距离雅典约 25 英里的马拉松平原登陆，而波斯人此前从未被希腊军队击败过。
Those in Athens who can afford armor, and this is a kind of, so it's a self-selecting group. They are basically a kind of an elite. They go out and they charge the Persians and they defeat them. And this is the memory that particularly people who are aristocratic, the people who are not from the lower classes, they really, really cherish it. But there is another great victory that is won basically by everyone. And so is the victory that is the toast of the lower classes,
雅典那些买得起盔甲的人，这是一群自我遴选的人。他们基本上是一个精英群体。他们出击冲向波斯人并击败了他们。这段记忆是特别被贵族阶层、那些不属于下层阶级的人所深深珍视的。但还有另一场伟大的胜利，基本上是由所有人共同赢得的。因此，这也是下层阶级为之干杯的胜利，
which is a naval battle that is fought 10 years later at Salamis. And again, we did an episode on this. And the salient thing about that is that whereas to fight in a phalanx, you need armor, to row in a boat, you don't need a big income. So everyone can do it. And the Athenians have built up this huge fleet between Marathon and Salamis with the sound of both trade and of the naval dockyards. And almost certainly as a result of the sense that it's the whole mass of the Athenian people,
这是一场在十年后于萨拉米斯进行的伟大海战。同样，我们也做过一期关于这个的节目。显而易见的一点是，要在方阵中战斗，你需要盔甲；而在船上划桨，你不需要丰厚的收入。所以每个人都可以做到。雅典人在马拉松和萨拉米斯之间建立起了这支庞大的舰队，伴随着贸易和海军船坞的声音。几乎可以肯定的是，正因为雅典民众的整体力量，
the demos that have won Salamis, the democracy becomes ever more radical. The sense that, of course, the aristocracy can continue to play a part. And indeed, the most famous Athenian democratic leader, Pericles, is himself impeccably aristocratic background. But the idea is that political power in Athens is wielded not just by those who are the traditional elites, but by the entire mass of the people. So right the way down to the poorest person who can pull an oar from the slums of Piraeus. And that sets up a kind of inherent tension within the mind of Plato, and indeed many other people, because it gets him wondering, what is the best form of government? There have been all these different kinds of government.
赢得萨拉米斯的雅典 demos（人民），使民主制变得更加激进。当然，贵族可以继续发挥作用的想法依然存在。事实上，最著名的雅典民主领袖伯里克利本人就拥有无可挑剔的贵族背景。但其核心思想是，雅典的政治权力不仅由传统精英掌握，而且由全体人民掌握。一直延伸到来自比雷埃夫斯贫民窟、能够拉动船桨的最穷的人。这在柏拉图的心中，以及许多其他人的心中，构成了某种内在的张力，因为它让他思考：最好的政府形式是什么？曾有过所有这些不同类型的政府。
Is monarchy better? Athens used to be a monarchy. Is aristocracy better? Or is democracy better? And these are questions that are focused by the fact that Athens, in alliance with Sparta, has defeated the Persians in 490 and then in 480. But a bit like the Soviet Union in America after the defeat of Hitler, the two great powers who've won this kind of heroic victory, they start to fall out. And in due course, they come to fight a war that the Athenians call the Peloponnesian War, the Spartans probably called the Athenian War. And this is the world that Plato is born into, a world in which
君主制更好吗？雅典曾经是君主制。贵族制更好吗？还是民主制更好？这些问题随着雅典与斯巴达结盟在公元前 490 年和 480 年击败波斯人而成为焦点。但有点像击败希特勒之后的苏联和美国，这两个赢得这种英雄般胜利的大国开始交恶。不久之后，他们爆发了一场战争，雅典人称之为伯罗奔尼撒战争，斯巴达人可能称之为雅典战争。这就是柏拉图出生的世界，一个
the memory of Athenian greatness at Marathon and at Salamis is politically charged, and a world in which Athens is in a kind of terrible death struggle with Sparta. A struggle it's going to lose, ultimately. Yes. So Plato is growing up as a kind of series of catastrophic events happen. So basically, the Athenians become hubristic. That comes from the Greek word hubris, which is this idea of a sense that you are overconfident, that you push your sense of greatness too far, and the gods then punish you. And the great hubristic adventure that the athenians launch is um a naval
雅典在马拉松和萨拉米斯的伟大记忆充满政治色彩的世界，一个雅典与斯巴达进行可怕生死搏杀的世界。一场最终会输掉的战争。是的。因此，随着一连串灾难性事件的发生，柏拉图正在长大。基本上，雅典人变得傲慢自大。这源于希腊语 hubris，这个词的意思是你过于自信，把自己的伟大感推得太远，然后诸神就会惩罚你。雅典人发起的伟大的傲慢冒险是……一次海军
expedition to go and conquer syracuse in sicily and is that alcibiades who who's in charge of that yeah so he's the kind of the glamorous playboy the great you know the idol of the athenian people and he pushes this scheme but it all goes horribly wrong um the athenian fleet the athenian army is wiped out. And Athens, from having been the great hegemon of Greece, is now in a desperate struggle. It's really, really on the back foot. And in the years that follow, it loses fleet after fleet after fleet until in 404, it has no choice but to surrender to the Spartans. The Spartans decide not to destroy Athens. They might have done, but they decide not to because there's a certain
远征，去征服西西里的叙拉古。那是阿尔西比亚德斯负责的吗？是的，所以他是那种迷人的花花公子，伟大的，你知道的，雅典人民的偶像，他推动了这个计划，但这一切都糟糕地搞砸了……雅典舰队、雅典军队被全歼了。雅典从希腊的伟大霸主地位，陷入了绝望的挣扎。它真的处境非常被动。在接下来的几年里，它一艘又一艘地失去舰队，直到公元前 404 年，它别无选择，只能向斯巴达人投降。斯巴达人决定不摧毁雅典。他们本可以这样做，但他们决定不这样做，因为对于雅典在波斯战争中所做的事情，仍有一种残存的感激之情，而且斯巴达人也不想消除对其他城市的潜在制衡力量。因此，他们做的是废除民主制，并扶植了后来被称为三十僭政的统治。这些是寡头、贵族，其中两人来自柏拉图的直系核心圈子。其中一个是他的叔叔，一个叫卡尔米德的人，另一个是柏拉图母亲的表弟。
residual sense of gratitude for what Athens had done in the Persian Wars, but also the Spartans don't want to remove a potential counterbalance to other cities. So what they do is they abolish the democracy and they install what comes to be remembered as rule by 30 tyrants. So these are oligarchs, aristocrats, two of whom come from Plato's immediate circle. So one of them is his uncle, a man called Charmides, and the other is the cousin of Plato's mother.
他是一个叫卡尔米德的人，另一个是柏拉图母亲的表弟。哦，呃，他是一个叫克里提亚斯的人。是的，克里提亚斯可能是——我的意思是，他在某种程度上似乎是三十僭政背后的推动力，他是其中最具人格魅力、最危险的人。克里提亚斯的名字出现在柏拉图谈论亚特兰蒂斯的其中一个信源中。我没记错吧？是的，你没记错。太好了。这就是在做铺垫。对。
And he is a man called charmides and the other is the cousin of plato's mother oh uh and he is a man called critias yeah and critias is probably i mean he seems to be in a way the um the kind of the motor behind the 30 tyrants he's the most charismatic he's the most dangerous of them critias gives his name to one of the sources in which Plato talks about Atlantis. Have I got that right? You have. Oh, great. That's setting that up. Right.
所以克里提亚斯和卡尔米德似乎曾邀请柏拉图加入，而柏拉图退缩了，因为他认为他们的政权是不公正的、违宪的。随着时间的推移，事实证明这是一个非常精明的识别行为，因为三十僭政被驱逐了。他们在战斗中被击败。民主制重新建立。在推翻三十僭政的战役中，克里提亚斯和卡尔米德被杀。所以柏拉图避免了被卷入其中。但与此同时，他对恢复后的民主制也充满敌意，因为在公元前 399 年，恢复后的民主制一直在追捕那些在某种程度上与被推翻的三十僭政政权有联系的人，他们处决了这个人，他一直是柏拉图伟大的
So Critias and Charmides seem to have asked Plato if he would join in, and Plato steps back because he sees their regime as unjust, as unconstitutional. And in due course, this proves to be a very shrewd act of recognition because the 30 tyrants get expelled. They're defeated in battle. The democracy gets re-established. And in the battle that overthrows the 30 tyrants, Critias is killed and Charmides. So Plato, he's avoided being dragged into that. But at the same time, he is also very hostile to the restored democracy because in 399, the restored democracy, which has been going after people who are to a degree associated with the topple regime of the 30 tyrants, execute the man who has been plato's great
灵感源泉、伟大的导师，他心目中雅典最伟大的人……一位哲学家，我确信我们所有的听众都听说过，不仅因为他出现在《阿比和阿弟的历险记》里，他叫苏格拉底。但苏格拉底也出现在《刺客信条：奥德赛》里，汤姆。是吗？我还没玩过，但也许有一天会玩。阿尔西比亚德斯也是。这就是我了解它的方式。显然不是通过读什么书。因此，苏格拉底被处死，官方罪名是拒绝尊敬雅典城邦尊崇的神明，引入了新神，并腐蚀了雅典的青年。柏拉图基本上把这视为一种司法谋杀的行为，所以他鄙视民主制，正如他也鄙视他叔叔的贵族政权一样。当时的柏拉图正处于二十多岁的中期，他出生于公元前 420 年代，而那是公元前 399 年，所以……是的。
inspiration his great teacher the man whom he regards as as the greatest man in athens um a philosopher who i'm sure all our listeners will have heard of not least because he appears in bill and ted he's called socrates but socrates is also in assassin's creed odyssey tom is he which i haven't yet but maybe one day. As is Alcibiades. That's how I know about it. It's obviously not through reading any books. So Socrates is put to death officially for having refused to honour the gods,
是的。他离开了雅典。对当时的柏拉图来说，雅典不是一个好地方。
honoured by the Athenian state, for having introduced new gods, and for having corrupted the youth of Athens. And Plato regards this basically as as an act of kind of judicial murder and so he he despises the democracy as he's also despised the the aristocratic regime of his uncle and plato at that point is in his mid-20s he's born in the 420s and that's 399 so yeah yeah. Yeah. And he, he, he leaves Athens. It's Athens is, is not a good place for him to be at this point.
所以他去了西西里，那里有很多各种各样的僭主。他特意去了叙拉古，在那里他开始形成这样一种想法：也许如果你能找到一个僭主或某种领袖，并在哲学上教育他、培训他，那么你也许就能拥有一个伟大的领袖。对，他试图将这一点付诸实践，结果并不是
So he goes to Sicily where there are lots of kind of tyrants. He specifically goes to Syracuse where he, he starts to develop the idea that perhaps if you can get a tyrant or a kind of a leader and, and school him in philosophy, train him, then perhaps you'll have a great leader right and he he tries to put this to the test it it it doesn't work out
非常成功。有传言说他最终甚至被卖为奴隶，不得不被从奴隶制中赎回……总之，这一切进展并不顺利。他回到了雅典，并创立了一所哲学学校。他把学校开在一处供奉着一个名不见经传的英雄阿卡德莫斯的树林里。因此，以这位名不见经传的英雄阿卡德莫斯的名字命名，柏拉图的学校后来被称为“学园”（Academy）。因此就有了“学者”（academics）、“学术界”（academia）以及诸如此类的词。他成为了一名伟大的老师、备受赞誉的老师，同时也是一位伟大的作家。关于柏拉图，有一点要说的是，他不仅是一位伟大的哲学家，也是有史以来最伟大的作家之一。我的意思是，他是一位极其伟大的文学工匠。我刚才提到他写过对话录。
brilliantly there are stories that he he ends up actually being sold into slavery and has to be redeemed from from slavery anyway so it all it it's it doesn't go well and And he comes back to Athens and he founds a philosophical school. And he does this in a grove that is sacred to a rather obscure hero called Academus. And so after Academus, this obscure hero, Plato's school comes to be called the Academy. So hence academics, academia, all that kind of thing uh and he becomes a great teacher very celebrated teacher but but also a great writer and one thing to say about plato is that he's not only a great philosopher he is also one of the greatest writers of all time i mean his his he is a great great literary craftsman and he. And I mentioned earlier that he wrote dialogue.
所以他极少直接撰写大段的散文。他会引入苏格拉底。因此，苏格拉底总是他那些小短剧中的一个核心人物。他还会引入各种其他角色。苏格拉底会谈论伦理学、灵魂不朽或现实的本质，所有这些他都会融入对话中，融入那种以苏格拉底为主角的戏剧性论述中。在所有这些主题中，有一个主题是：什么样的政体才能构成一个理想的国家？什么样的政体才能构成理想的城邦？城邦（polis）是一种城市国家。所以雅典是一个城邦，
So he very rarely writes just kind of straight chunks of prose. He will introduce Socrates. So Socrates is invariably a figure within his kind of like little dramas. And he'll introduce various other characters. Socrates will talk about ethics or the immortality of the soul or the nature of reality and, all of these things he will kind of put into dialogues, kind of dramatic discourses in which Socrates is invariably the kind of the leader. And all these topics, among them is the topic of what would make an ideal state? What would make an ideal polis? Polis is a kind of city state. So Athens is a polis.
斯巴达是一个城邦。组织一个国家的最好方式是什么？是的。柏拉图关于这个问题最著名的文本被称为《理想国》——这是它的英文名字。在这篇对话中，苏格拉底基本上回顾了各种政府形式——君主制、寡头制、民主制，对它们进行了全部检验，发现它们都差强人意。然后他开始构想他关于完美政府系统的想法。他基本上认为，只有当一个国家由某种特定阶层的人来指引时，它才能从失政和不义中拯救出来。你认为那是哪个阶层的人？
Sparta is a polis. What is the best way to organize a state yeah and the most famous text that plato writes about this question is called the republic i mean that's the english name for it and socrates in this dialogue basically goes through he looks at all the various forms of government say monarchyigarchy, democracy, puts them all to the test, finds them all wanting. And he then starts to formulate his idea of what a perfect system of government would be. And he basically argues that a state can only be redeemed from misgovernment, from injustice, if a state is guided by a certain class of person? What do you think that class of person is?
那是一群跟他自己差不多的人，汤姆。有趣的是，这往往就是这么运作的。所以基本上是由哲学家来统治，即哲学家国王。对。所以柏拉图基本上是在说，如果由像他这样的人来统治，一切都会变得非常棒。嗯，正如我们在社交媒体上所知，学者永远是政治领域的最佳法官。绝对是的。
It's a people not unlike himself, Tom. It's funny how that often works out. So it's basically ruled by philosophers, philosopher kings. Right. So basically Plato is saying everything would be brilliant if it was ruled by people like him. Well, as we know from social media, academics are always the best judges in politics. Absolutely. Yes.
所以这是一个非常古老的传统，一直追溯到那个供奉英雄阿卡德莫斯的树林。这就是柏拉图心中的“卡利波利斯”（Calipolis，意为美善之城）理想，他这样称呼它，一座完美的城市，一个理想的国家。所以《理想国》基本上是关于它的哲学的。这是一场气势宏大的哲学讨论。但他无法放下这个主题，他又通过另外两种方式对其进行了探讨。其中之一是……一本书叫《法律篇》，与他的其他作品相比，这本书非常枯燥，它基本上
So this is a very ancient tradition going all the way back to that grove sacred to the hero Academus. And so this is Plato's ideal of a Calipolis, as he calls it, a perfect city, an ideal state. So the Republic is basically about the philosophy of it. It's a kind of great sweeping philosophical discussion. But he can't leave the theme alone. And he pursues it in two other ways. So one of them is um a book called the laws which is a very kind of compared to his other works kind of very arid and it it's essentially
名副其实，是一份关于如何治理国家的法律清单。然后还有另外两篇对话，分别叫《蒂迈欧篇》和《克里提亚斯篇》。《蒂迈欧篇》和《克里提亚斯篇》都是苏格拉底正在进行的对话的参与者。其中第一篇是《蒂迈欧篇》。《蒂迈欧篇》的背景设定在雅典的一个节日期间。那是秋天，很可能在公元前 421 年。我们几乎可以确定日期。它似乎设定在《理想国》中戏剧化讨论的那天之后的第二天。但又不完全是，因为某些事情已经改变了……因此，《蒂迈欧篇》的开头是对苏格拉底和他的伙伴们如何决定理想国家的回顾。实际上，哲学家国王已经从中消失了。取而代之的是，你得到了一个守护者阶层，他们是国中领袖的紧密
what it says on the tin it's a it's a list of laws about how a state could be governed yeah and then there are two other dialogues and these are called the timaeus and the Critias. Timaeus and Critias are both of them participants in a dialogue that Socrates is conducting. The first of these is the Timaeus. The Timaeus is set in Athens during a festival. It's autumn, probably in 49. We can almost be precise about the date. It seems to be set a day after the discussion that that is uh dramatized in the republic right but it's also not because certain things have changed so um the beginning of timaeus is a kind of recap of of how socrates and his pals had decided what the ideal state was. And actually, the philosopher kings have gone from this. And instead, what you get is you get a class of guardians who are a kind of cohesive
群体，没有私有财产，没有个人的家庭生活，他们的工作本质上就是把其他所有人都塑造成一种……我的意思是，那些真的是学者啊，汤姆，没有私有财产，也没有……好吧，我的意思是，想象一下你在推特上能想象到的最美德的人来掌控你的生活，谁会不想要那个呢？这基本上就是柏拉图所提议的。在这篇对话中有四个人：苏格拉底本人；来自叙拉古的将军赫尔墨克拉底；来自意大利一个叫洛克里斯的城市的蒂迈欧；
group of the leading men in the state who have no private property, no individual family life, and it's their job essentially to kind of fashion everybody else into a kind of i mean those really are academics tom no private property and no well i mean yes i mean imagine the most virtuous people you can on twitter running your life and that's who wouldn't want that that's that's that's basically that's basically what plato is proposing um so there are four people in this dialogue there's socrates himself. There's Hermocrates, who is a general from Syracuse. There's Timaeus, who is a man from Italy, a city called Locris.
还有这个叫克里提亚斯的家伙，正如你所说，他不仅与柏拉图有亲戚关系，还将领导三十僭政。所以他并不是一个完全中立的人物。这四个人——苏格拉底、赫尔墨克拉底、蒂迈欧、克里提亚斯——在讨论理想的国家应该是什么样的。苏格拉底说他想看到一个理想的国家真正投入行动。因此，本质上，他想看到这是如何在历史中、在时间中运作的，而不仅仅是作为一个理想的抽象概念。于是克里提亚斯转过身对苏格拉底说，他刚好有这样一个故事。那么听我说，苏格拉底，他说。我有一个故事，它既完全荒谬、完全光怪陆离，然而同时又完全真实。哦，汤姆，这就是亚特兰蒂斯的故事吗？
And there is this guy, Critias, who, as you said, is not only related to Plato, but will go on to lead the 30 tyrants. So it's not an entirely neutral figure. So they're talking about what an ideal state should be, these four guys, Socrates, Hermocrates, Timaeus, Critias. And Socrates says that he wants to see an ideal state actually in action. So essentially, he wants to see how this operates within history, within time, rather than just as a kind of ideal abstraction. And so Critias then turns around and he says to Socrates, he has just the thing. Then listen to me, Socrates, he says. I have a story that is simultaneously completely barking, completely fantastical, and yet at the same time, completely true. Oh, Tom, is that the story of Atlantis?
既疯狂又真实。太棒了。真是个悬念。一个“topos”（母题），非常古怪、不合时宜、离奇。正如我们将在第二部分中发现的那样，这就是亚特兰蒂斯的故事。天哪。所以休息过后，请和我们一起了解亚特兰蒂斯的真相。我是玛丽娜·海德。
So mad and true. Brilliant. What a cliffhanger. A topos, very odd, kind of out of place, weird. And that, as we will find out in part two, is the story of Atlantis. Crikey. So join us after the break for the truth about Atlantis. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的 restis》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想获得无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
欢迎回到《历史的 restis》。今天前半段播客结束时留下了一个悬念，因为克里提亚斯即将向苏格拉底展开一个既离奇荒诞又完全真实的故事。汤姆，这会是亚特兰蒂斯的故事吗？快讲讲。正是如此。所以克里提亚斯透露，这个故事其实是关于雅典的。所以理想的国家就是雅典。雅典之所以没有人记得它，是因为这个故事已经被时间以及折磨人类的、周而复始的毁灭周期所抹去了。这非常符合格雷厄姆·汉考克的风格。这就是我们在引言中听到的全球大灾难。是的。所以你可能会想，既然如此，克里提亚斯是怎么知道的呢？
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We ended the first half of today's podcast on something of a cliffhanger because Critias is about to unfold to Socrates a story that's both utterly fabulous and completely true. And Tom, is this going to be the story of Atlantis? Do tell. It is. So Critias reveals that this story is actually about Athens. So the ideal state is Athens. And the reason that nobody in Athens remembers it is because the story has been obliterated by time and by the repeated cycles of destruction that have afflicted mankind. So that's very Graham Hancock. That's the global cataclysm we heard about in the introduction. Yes. So you may well wonder, well wonder well in that case how does critias know
他给我们做出了非常精准的解释：他说，在他 10 岁时，他从他祖父那里听说了这个故事，他祖父是从他父亲那里听来的，他父亲是从一个叫梭伦的人那里听来的，梭伦是一个立法者，雅典的立法者，对吧，他曾为雅典颁布过法律，然后出外游历。他去了埃及，在埃及，他从埃及的祭司那里听到了这个故事。听起来是一个无可挑剔的信源链，汤姆。绝对如此。正如格雷厄姆·汉考克毫无疑问会说的那样：无可辩驳。当他在埃及的时候，祭司们基本上在嘲笑他，因为梭伦什么也记不住。他们说出了那句著名的台词：“啊，梭伦，梭伦，你们希腊人永远是
about it and he gives us a very precise explanation so he says that when he was 10 he heard it from his grandfather who heard it from his father who heard it from a man called solon who was um a law giver athenian law giver right who had given kind of laws to Athens and then gone off on his travels. And he'd gone to Egypt and in Egypt, he had heard it from the priests of Egypt. That sounds like an unimpeachable chain of sources, Tom. Absolutely. Beyond reasonable doubt, as Graham Hancock would no doubt say. And when he's in Egypt, the priests basically laugh at him because Solon can't remember anything. And they come out with this kind of famous line, oh, Solon, Solon, you Greeks are always
小孩子。希腊没有老人。”埃及祭司之所以能这么说，是因为埃及得天独厚，凭借拥有尼罗河，抵御了所有淹没人类的各种自然灾害。梭伦感到很兴趣，便问：“你们说的究竟是什么样的自然灾害？”祭司们以法厄同的故事为例向我们解释，在希腊神话中，法厄同是太阳神赫利俄斯的儿子，他最终驾驶太阳战车却无法控制，
children. There are no old men in Greece. And the reason the priests can say this, the Egyptian priests, is because Egypt uniquely has been proof against all these various natural disasters that have overwhelmed humanity because they have the Nile. And Solon is intrigued and says, well, what kind of natural disasters are you talking about? And the priests give us an example of the story of Phaeton, who in the Greek myth is the son of Helios, the sun god, who ends up driving the chariot,
太阳战车俯冲而下，将大地半数烧焦，随后又直冲高空将其冻结。埃及祭司透露，这其实并不是真的，这个故事是一个神话，用来解释实际发生过的事情，即一颗彗星撞击了地球。是的，这再次引人入胜，因为这正是格雷厄姆·汉考克在你介绍的那段话中所写的。埃及祭司声称他们的记录可以追溯到 8,000 年前。他们说，他们要讲的故事发生在那之前 1,000 年。所以总共是 9,000 年。格雷厄姆·汉考克就是这样得出他的计算结果的。他谈论的是 11,600 年前。这就是柏拉图设定亚特兰蒂斯故事背景的时间，
can't control it. And the chariot of the sun sweeps down and half burns the earth and then sweep goes right up into the heights and freezes it and the egyptian priests reveal that this wasn't actually true that this story is a myth explaining what had actually happened which was that a comet had hit the earth yeah so again intriguing because that's what graham hunker is writing about in that passage that you introduced it. The Egyptian priests claim that their records go back 8,000 years. And they say that the story that they're going to tell was 1,000 years before that. So that's 9,000 years in total. So that's how Graham Hancock came to his calculation. He was talking about 11,600 years ago. This is whenato was setting the story
他是这样得出他的日期的。那么，在这篇对话、在克里提亚斯讲述这个故事之前 9,000 年，发生了什么？克里提亚斯解释说……他指出，亚特兰蒂斯存在于海格力斯之柱、直布罗陀海峡之外的大洋中。那是一个比非洲和亚洲加起来还要大的岛屿。鉴于我们一直在做的关于哥伦布的系列节目，多米尼克，这太迷人了，他说，旅行者可以从亚特兰蒂斯继续前往更多的岛屿，并从这些岛屿前往包围着整个海洋的、我们对面的大陆。天哪。所以，是的，非常非常引人入胜。
of atlantis that's how he he gets his date so what happens um 9 000 years before this dialogue before critias the story that critias is giving well critias explains he says that um atlantis exists out in the ocean beyond the straits of Gibraltar, the Pillars of Hercules. It was an island that was bigger than Africa and Asia put together. And in light of the series that we were doing on Columbus, Dominic, fascinating, he says, it was possible for travelers to go onwards from Atlantis to further islands and from these islands onwards to the continent opposite us and which surrounds the entire ocean. Crikey. So, yeah, I mean, kind of very, very intriguing.
他说亚特兰蒂斯是一个强大的帝国。它入侵了欧洲，入侵了亚洲，它的目标是征服整个世界，因为它充满了傲慢。唯一挺身而出抵抗这场帝国狂飙突进的力量就是古雅典城。克里提亚斯这样评价当时的雅典：在 9,000 年前，她的勇气和军事实力是无与伦比的。有时她站在希腊人的最前列，
And he says that Atlantis was a mighty power. It invaded Europe, it invaded Asia, and its aim was to conquer the whole world because it was full of hubris. And the only power that stood against this imperial onslaught was the ancient city of Athens. And Critias says of Athens then, 9,000 years ago, her courage and her military prowess were unexampled. Sometimes she stood at the head of the Greeks.
有时在被所有人抛弃时，她孤军奋战。她迎难而上。她击败了入侵者，并为自己的胜利树立了一座纪念碑。她拯救了那些尚未被奴役的人免于失去自由。她慷慨地解放了所有居住在海格力斯之柱以内的人。这场伟大的胜利赢得了。雅典人将欧洲和亚洲从亚特兰蒂斯的入侵中拯救出来。然后突然之间，可怕的地震、可怕的洪水爆发了，雅典军队被全歼了。这就是为什么雅典忘记了这场光荣胜利的记忆，
Sometimes when abandoned by everyone else, she fought alone. She braved every danger. She defeated the invaders and raised a monument to her victory. She saved those who had not yet been enslaved from losing their freedom. And she ungrudgingly liberated all those who lived inside the pillars of Hercules. This great victory is won. The Athenians save Europe and Asia from the Atlantean invasion. And then suddenly, terrible earthquakes, terrible floods, the Athenian army is wiped out. So that's why Athens comes to forget the very memory of this glorious victory.
而亚特兰蒂斯则沉入波涛之下。亚特兰蒂斯留下的全部东西，就是海格力斯之柱外大洋中的一片泥泞之海。好吧。一片泥泞之海。大西洋里其实没有一片泥泞之海，对吧？这就是柏拉图所说的。这就是克里提亚斯所说的。我把它记下来。你可能很想反思一下，因为正如苏格拉底在听到这个故事时所指出的，
And Atlantis sinks beneath the waves. And all that is left of Atlantis is a great sea of mud in the ocean beyond the pillars of Hercules. Okay. A sea of mud. There's not really a sea of mud in the Atlantic, is there? This is what Plato says. This is what Critias is saying. I'll put it down. And you may well want to reflect because, ascrates points out when he's heard this story,
关于它最显着的一点是，它确实发生了，而不仅仅是某人编造的某种魔幻故事。我在这里稍微意译了一下，但这基本上就是苏格拉底所表达的倾向。因此，柏拉图在那里反复强调的想法是，这是真的。这真的发生了。这不是幻想。这是真实的历时。好吧，我受教了。对亚特兰蒂斯的粉丝来说非常不幸的是，蒂迈欧随后开始发散思维，开始谈论宇宙学之类的事情。而显然每个人想要的都只是更多关于亚特兰蒂斯的内容。但幸运的是，我们接着进入了第二篇对话，实际上
the salient thing about it is that it actually happened and isn't just kind of some magic that someone's made up. I slightly paraphrase there, but that's essentially the drift of what Socrates is saying. So what Plato is hammering home there is the idea that this is true. This actually happened. This isn't a fantasy. This is actual history. Well, I've been educated. Rather unfortunately for fans of Atlantis, Timaeus then starts spiraling off and he starts talking about cosmology and stuff. Whereas obviously all everyone wants is a bit more about Atlantis. But fortunately, we then move on to the second dialogue, which is actually
就叫《克里提亚斯篇》，我们在那里回到了正题。我们回到了克里提亚斯讲述这篇对话的时间点 9,000 年前的雅典和亚特兰蒂斯。所以雅典听起来并不完全像柏拉图时代的雅典。这座城市的守护者基本上是勇士阶层。他们生活在共餐的群体中。不是哲学家吗？不，到目前为止他们是守护者。他们是一种勇士精英。他们生活在共餐的群体中。他们没有黄金或白银。雅典本身拥有大得多的领土。它似乎建在内陆，或者至少它的遗址周围有更多的土地，相比于后来它建在内陆的情况……或者至少它的遗址周围拥有更多的土地，拥有 20,000 名勇士，所以它是一座伟大的
called Critias, where we get back to it. And we go back to both to Athens and Atlantis as it existed 9,000 years before the time that Critias is giving this dialogue. So Athens doesn't entirely sound like the Athens of Plato's time. So the guardians of the city are basically the warrior class. They live in shared messes. Not philosophers? No, by now they're guardians. They're kind of warrior elite. They live in shared messes. They have no gold or silver. Athens itself has a much larger territory. It seems to have been built inland, or at least its site is surrounded by a lot more land than it's come to have been built inland or at least its site has is surrounded by a lot more land than than it's come to have it has 20 000 warriors so it's a great um city of infantry
步兵城市。
there is no mention whatsoever of a fleet so that is plato's portrait of athens as an ideal state so that sounds a bit like sparta well we you may think that we will come to that in due course and we're wondering what exactly plato is doing with all this then you have atlantis so athens is obviously the city of athena it's in greek its name is athena yeah um and poseidon had wanted to have um athens but loses that competition. So he gets Atlantis. He predictably, he founds a line of kings by raping a girl. Long line of kings. And the characteristics of these kings is that they are fabulously wealthy. I mean, wealthy beyond the dreams of any previous royal dynasty. They rule lands that are full of elephants. Their lands are teeming with
完全没有提到任何舰队，这就是柏拉图心目中雅典作为理想国的写照，这听起来有点像斯巴达，好吧，你可能会觉得我们会在适的时候谈到这一点，我们在想柏拉图到底在用这一切做什么，然后你有了亚特兰蒂斯，所以雅典显然是雅典娜的城市，希腊语里它的名字就是雅典娜，对，呃，波塞冬本来想要雅典，但输掉了那场竞争，所以他得到了亚特兰蒂斯，不出所料，他通过强暴一个女孩建立了一脉国王，长长的一系国王，这些国王的特点是他们拥有难以置信的财富，我是说，财富超越了以往任何王室朝代的梦想，他们统治的土地上到处都是大象，他们的土地上挤满了
spices of all kinds. They build the most splendid palace that has ever been built. The palace is, Atlantis itself is threaded with great canals. The capital city is surrounded by circular walls, each of different colors yeah it's a bit like minas tirith there's a there's a lovely illustration of this in graham hancock's series there's a sort of cgi i remember the circular walls and the canals and the great stuff the terrific palace looks it looks a looks a great place tom yeah um and the king himself is guarded by elite troops who um who who are called spear carriers they're not they're not rsc spear carriers you don't have any lines no no they're
各种各样的香料，他们建造了有史以来最宏伟的宫殿，宫殿是，亚特兰蒂斯本身就纵横交错着伟大的运河，首都周围环绕着圆形的墙壁，每堵墙的颜色都不同，这有点像米那斯提力斯，格雷厄姆·汉考克的系列里有一个这方面的精美插图，有一种类似CGI的画面，我记得那些圆形的墙壁、运河和了不起的东西，那座极好的宫殿，看起来，看起来是个好地方，汤姆，呃，国王本人由精锐部队守卫，他们，他们，他们被称为长矛手，他们不是，他们不是皇家莎士比亚剧团的长矛手，你没有台词，不，不，他们是
an elite squad of crack picked men right okay very good um and also atlantis unlike athens is absolutely heaving with harbors and dockyards right Right. Expand that in an island, to be fair. Plato writes a description of it, that the largest harbour was full of ships and merchants arriving from everywhere, and it echoed to the din of their shouting, and the hubbub and the clattering never ceased, but went on all day and night. It also has mines. Okay. So all this gold and silver.
一支精锐的精挑细选的部队，对，好的，非常好，而且亚特兰蒂斯和雅典不同，到处都是港口和造船厂，对，对，平心而论，在一个岛上放大这一点，柏拉图对此有一段描述，最大的港口挤满了从各地赶来的船只和商人，那里回荡着他们的叫喊声、喧闹声和此起彼伏的嘈杂声，从白天到黑夜从未停止，它还有矿山，好的，所以所有这些黄金和白银。
Yeah. So what is going on here? Well, I mean, Socrates said it was true. Graham Hancock says it's true who am i to disagree there is an alternative theory which is that plato completely made it up okay and i'm going to pin my colors to the mast and say that i think that that is absolutely what happened you astound me tom um and i think that there are two things that Plato is drawing on here. The first and the least interesting is that Greece lives in quite a geologically unstable part of the world. So earthquakes, tsunamis, Plato has lived through them.
对，那么这里到底发生了什么？嗯，我的意思是，苏格拉底说这是真的，格雷厄姆·汉考克说这是真的，我又是谁敢反驳呢，还有另一种理论，那就是柏拉图完全是凭空捏造的，好吧，我要表明我的立场，并说我认为这绝对是发生的事情，你让我大吃一惊，汤姆，嗯，我认为柏拉图在这里借鉴了两件事，第一件也是最不有趣的一点是，希腊生活在一个地质相当不稳定的世界部分，所以地震、海啸，柏拉图都经历过。
So 426, around the time that Plato is being born, there's an earthquake that forces the Spartans who were invading Attica at the time to retreat. And a tsunami drowns an entire city. And there is also a fort that is partially destroyed by a tsunami. It's an Athenian fort, and it's near an island that is called Atlante. So this is recorded in the history of the Peloponnesian War by an Athenian general called Thucydides, which Plato would undoubtedly have read. So he would know that. And 373, when Plato is, what, kind of late 40s, a city called Helici is completely drowned by a tsunami after an earthquake. And this earthquake, again, is attributed to the anger of the gods and specifically to Poseidon. So there is that sense.
所以在公元前426年，大约在柏拉图出生的时候，发生了一场地震，迫使当时正在入侵阿提卡的斯巴达人撤退，一场海啸淹没了一整座城市，还有一个堡垒被海啸部分摧毁，这是一个雅典的堡垒，它靠近一个叫做阿特兰蒂的岛屿，这被一位名叫修昔底德的雅典将军写在他的《伯罗奔尼撒战争史》中，柏拉图无疑读过这本书，所以他会知道这一点，而在公元前373年，当柏拉图大概是40多岁的时候，一座名叫赫利刻的城市在地震后被海啸完全淹没，这场地震再次被归咎于诸神的愤怒，特别是波塞冬的愤怒，所以有这样一种感觉。
Tom, what about the theory that I always read, which is that the Greeks would have had some sort of ancestral folk memory of the explosion, the eruption of Thera, Santorini, in 1600 BC, the one that had great consequences for Crete and the Minoan civilization and so on. People always claim that Atlantis is inspired by memories of that. Are you not buying that argument when you think about Plato and all his history of earthquakes? Well, a massive spoiler, no.
汤姆，我一直读到的那个理论怎么样，就是希腊人在公元前1600年对锡拉岛（圣托里尼）的爆发有过某种祖先的民间记忆，那次爆发对克里特岛和米诺斯文明等产生了巨大的影响，人们总是声称亚特兰蒂斯是受对那段记忆的启发，当你想到柏拉图和他的所有地震历史时，你难道不买账这个论点吗？嗯，一个巨大的剧透，不。
Right. But in our next episode, we can look at the various various series and that's definitely one of the theories right i mean if anyone was a familiar with this story there's no evidence for it in any greek myth or any greek story beforehand so it would imply that plato uniquely has come across it and i suppose what you're saying is that plato doesn't need to to be interested in earthquakes and tsunamis. He doesn't need to be reaching back thousands of years. No. He's got them in his own lifetime or the lifetime of people around him.
对，但在我们的下一集中，我们可以看看各种各样的系列，这绝对是其中一个理论，对吧，我的意思是，如果有人熟悉这个故事，在任何希腊神话或之前的任何希腊故事中都没有证据表明这一点，所以这意味着柏拉图是独一无二地遇到了这个故事，我想你的意思是柏拉图不需要对地震和海啸感兴趣，他不需要追溯到几千年前，不，他在他自己的一生中或他周围的人的一生中就经历过这些。
Absolutely. But also the specifics of the story, I think, I have a theory. Okay. And my theory is that, you know, I said Plato is a great literary craftsman. And I think that what he is constructing with the story of Atlantis is, in a way, the first parody of history, the first reworking of history as a kind of fiction. Because Plato is born and lives at a time when the very discipline of history is emerging. So I mentioned Thucydides, this kind of very bleak writer describing the war between Athens and Sparta, kind of pitiless analyst of how power functions. Yeah. But Thucydides is himself, he's not the first great historian a title that goes to herodotus who you know i you love herodotus tom much cherish i've translated him and everything
完全正确，但除了故事的具体细节之外，我想，我有一个理论，好的，我的理论是，你知道，我说过柏拉图是一个伟大的文学工匠，我认为他用亚特兰蒂斯的故事构建的，在某种程度上，是历史的第一个模仿，是将历史作为一种小说的第一次重新加工，因为柏拉图出生并生活在一个历史这门学科正在兴起的时代，所以我提到了修昔底德，这个描述雅典和斯巴达之间战争的非常阴郁的作家，一个对权力如何运作的冷酷分析师，是的，但修昔底德本人，他不是第一位伟大的历史学家，这个称号属于希罗多德，你知道的，汤姆，你很喜欢希罗多德，非常珍视他，我翻译过他的作品等等
um and herodotus tells the story of the persian invasions of greece and i think that essentially what plato is doing with the story of atantis and its war against Athens, as you pointed out, sounds very like Sparta. He is taking elements from Herodotus and he's taking elements from Thucydides and he's blurring and blending them, essentially to construct a kind of parodic riff on how the Athenians see their immediate past. If you think about the story of a great imperial empire that Plato has listed the attributes of Atlantis, it has elephants, it has spices. This is what the Persians command command they command the elephants and spices of distant india it's one of the wonders of of their of their great empire um the most splendid palace ever built the persian kings are famous for their palaces right persepolis or wherever yeah persepolis susa um specifically we mentioned that the city with the circular walls in in herodotus's account of ekbatana which is the capital of media which is
呃，希罗多德讲述了波斯人入侵希腊的故事，我认为柏拉图用亚特兰蒂斯的故事以及它对雅典的战争所做的事情，正如你所指出的，听起来非常像斯巴达，他吸收了希罗多德的元素，也吸收了修昔底德的元素，并将它们模糊和融合，本质上是为了构建一个讽刺性的即兴创作，关于雅典人如何看待他们眼前的过去，如果你想想柏拉图列出的亚特兰蒂斯属性的那个伟大的帝国，它有大象，有香料，这就是波斯人所掌控的，他们掌控着遥远印度的象与香，这是他们庞大帝国的奇迹之一，呃，有史以来最宏伟的宫殿，波斯国王以他们的宫殿而闻名，对吧，波斯波利斯或其他地方，是的，波斯波利斯，苏萨，呃，具体我们提到过那座有着圆形城墙的城市，在希罗多德对埃克巴坦那的描述中，埃克巴坦那是米底的首都，
um the medes and the persians are kind of you know closely associated peoples ekbatana likewise is described by herodotus as having circular walls with made of different colors so there seems a kind of clear echo of that yeah um the canals the the land that is famous for canals is mesopotamia babylonia it's famous for for the size and vastness of its walls, as Babylon was. The elite troops that carry the spears, these are the immortals. The immortals, when they march, they carry their spears upside down on their shoulders. This is what they're called. So the echoes of the Persian kings and the vast empire that they rule is very, very evident in the description of Atlantis.
呃，米底人和波斯人是一种，你知道的，密切相关的民族，希罗多德也将埃克巴坦那描述为拥有不同颜色制成的圆形城墙，所以这似乎有一种清晰的呼应，对吧，呃，运河，以运河闻名的土地是美索不达米亚，巴比伦尼亚，它以城墙的规模和浩瀚而闻名，正如巴比伦那样，携带长矛的精锐部队，这些是不死军，不死军行进时，把长矛倒扛在肩上，他们就是这样被称为的，所以对波斯国王及其统治的庞大帝国的呼应，在对亚特兰蒂斯的描述中是非常非常明显的。
Okay, that surprises me. And by the way, I find that very convincing. I love all that. That Atlantis is a parody of Persia. I had foolishly thought you were going to say that Atlantis was a parody of Athens. Well, so it is as well. Okay. And this is the genius of it. Because, of course, Atlantis has har parody of Athens. Well, so it is as well. Okay. And this is the genius of it
好的，这让我感到惊讶，顺便说一句，我觉得这非常有说服力，我喜欢这一切，亚特兰蒂斯是对波斯的讽刺，我愚蠢地以为你会说亚特兰蒂斯是对雅典的讽刺，嗯，它也是，好的，这就是它的天才之处，因为，当然，亚特兰蒂斯有，对雅典的讽刺，嗯，它也是，好的，这就是它的天才之处
because, of course, Atlantis has harbours and dockyards. It has a Deimos that makes endless din, endless chaos, and it has mines. And it was the discovery of the silver mine a few years before the Battle of Salamis that enabled the Athenians first to build a fleet.
因为，当然，亚特兰蒂斯拥有港口和造船厂，它拥有制造无休止喧嚣、无休止混乱的民众，它拥有矿山，正是在萨拉米斯战役前几年发现银矿，才使雅典人能够首次建造舰队。
So it's a blending of Persia and Athens. Yes. And the implication of that is that the Athenian democracy and the Persian monarchy in Athens have become interfused. So everything that had enabled Athens to stand firm against Persia, they have now become in a a sense, a kind of an equipped democracy, had become a parody of the Persian monarchy. So Atlantis is a Persianised Athens, basically. for a further complication of this which is again as you pointed out that athens this ideal state that has no dockyards you know back in back in the the kind of the palmy days of its ancient greatness yeah it sounds like sparta you know you're absolutely right these are you know elite
所以这是波斯和雅典的融合，是的，其含义是雅典民主制和雅典的波斯君主制已经融为一体，因此，所有使雅典能够在波斯面前坚定立场的因素，在某种意义上，变成了一种装备精良的民主制，变成了波斯君主制的讽刺，所以亚特兰蒂斯基本上就是一个波斯化的雅典，为了对此作进一步的复杂化，正如你所指出的，雅典这个没有造船厂的理想国，你知道，回到它古代伟大的全盛时期，是的，听起来像斯巴达，你知道，你完全正确，这些是，你知道的，精锐的
bands of warriors who live in shared messes the The Spartans notoriously had no gold or silver. You know, their currency were great kind of iron ingots. And the contrast is, you know, Plato is describing Atlantis as a city that is a great mecca of trade. The whole point of ancient Athens, as seen by Plato, you know, this ideal city is that it doesn't have trade, it doesn't have ships, it doesn't have fleets. It just has this kind of warrior elite who live in messes and who, in a sense, are a kind of idealized version of Sparta. So in other words, this is a political literary conceit in which Atlantis stands in for a sort of decadent, maritime, Persianized Athens or Athenized Persia. And Athens, in inverted commas, is a kind of
过着集体生活的战士群体，斯巴达人臭名昭著地没有黄金或白银，你知道，他们的货币是那种巨大的铁锭，而鲜明的对比是，你知道，柏拉图将亚特兰蒂斯描述为一个作为伟大贸易中心的城市，在柏拉图看来，古代雅典的全部意义，你知道，这个理想国就是它没有贸易，没有船只，没有舰队，它只有这种生活在集体食堂中的战士精英，在某种程度上，他们是斯巴达的某种理想化版本，换句话说，这是一个政治文学构思，其中亚特兰蒂斯代表了一种颓废的、海上的、波斯化的雅典或雅典化的波斯，而加引号的雅典则是
version of Sparta with all those virtues that he's attributing to. But that seems an odd thing for Plato to be sort of... Because the implication is quite pro-Spartan. Well, Plato is quite into Sparta. I mean, the Athenian elites, particularly the kind of aristocratic ones,
斯巴达的一个版本，具备了他所归因的所有那些美德，但这对于柏拉图来说似乎是一件奇怪的事情……因为这意味着相当亲斯巴达，嗯，柏拉图相当迷恋斯巴达，我的意思是，雅典精英，特别是那些贵族精英，
are quite interested in Sparta. There is a sense Athenian elites, particularly the kind of aristocratic ones, are quite interested in Sparta. There is a sense in which- Because they're conscious that Sparta beat them and therefore they want to understand why? No, I think it's less that. I think it's the idea that there's a kind of deep, deep vein of snobbery that runs through Greek philosophy. The contempt for the masses is very, very strong. and there's a feeling that sparta in a way offers the kind of more disciplined and more serious and more intense way of organizing a city than the chaos and the kind of the follies as they see it the kind of the tendency of the people to vote for brexit all that kind of stuff i knew you were going to go there i just well you know
对斯巴达相当感兴趣，在某种意义上——因为他们意识到斯巴达打败了他们，因此他们想了解原因？不，我觉得没那么简单，我觉得这是一种观点，即希腊哲学中贯穿着一种极深极深的势利感，对大众的轻蔑非常非常强烈，有一种感觉，即斯巴达在某种程度上提供了一种比混乱和愚蠢（如他们所见）、人民投票支持脱欧的倾向等等更具纪律性、更严肃、更激进的城市组织方式，我早知道你会扯到那儿，我只是——好吧，你知道的，
there's a kind of i mean if you want to map the contempt that academics on Twitter feel for people who vote for Brexit, it's not an entirely, I think, far-fetched analogy as to how philosophers in Athens view the mistakes made by the democracy. This is very much their take. But what Plato is doing is essentially, he's looking at how can you write philosophy, this model of an ideal city, and put it within time. Because Socrates is absolutely right that there's no point in talking about an ideal city if you can't show that it would actually function within an actual narrative. But there's a kind of implicit acknowledgement that this is very difficult because what Plato is doing is taking elements from the two great works of
有一种——我的意思是，如果你想描绘推特上的学者对投票支持脱欧的人的轻蔑，我认为这并非一个完全牵强的类比，关于雅典的哲学家们如何看待民主所犯的错误，这很大程度上就是他们的看法，但柏拉图所做的本质上是，他在研究如何才能书写哲学，即理想国的这种模式，并将其置于时间之中，因为苏格拉底完全正确，如果你不能证明它实际上会在现实的叙事中运作，谈论理想国就没有任何意义，但这有一种隐含的承认，即这非常困难，因为柏拉图所做的是汲取了已撰写的两部伟大历史著作的元素，
history that have been written. Herodotus' history of the Persian Wars, Thucydides' history of the Peloponnesian War, and he's taking elements and he's mixing them up to kind of create what seems to be a narrative about something that happened nine millennia before, but is actually absolutely about the events of the previous century. And I think it's brilliantly, brilliantly done. And the tribute to that, the proof of that is the fact that the story of Atlantis has haunted people ever since. Although having said that, the proof of that is the fact that the story of Atlantis has haunted people ever since. Although having said that, one of the things that is interesting about the reception of the story told by Plato is that very few people initially seem to have actually believed that it was true.
希罗多德的《波斯战争史》和修昔底德的《伯罗奔尼撒战争史》，他吸收了其中的元素并将它们混合在一起，创造出似乎是关于九千年前发生的事情的叙事，但实际上完全是关于上个世纪的事件，我认为这做得非常非常出色，而对此的赞誉，对此的证明，就是亚特兰蒂斯的故事此后一直萦绕在人们心头这一事实，尽管话虽如此，证明这一点的另一个事实是，关于柏拉图所讲故事的接受情况，有趣的一点是，最初似乎极少有人真正相信它是真的。
People absolutely seem to have understood what he was doing with this. So that's fascinating. So Aristotle, Plato's student, with Plato, one of the two towering figures of Greek philosophy, he never mentions Atlantis, even though Aristotle is fascinated both by constitutions and by things like earthquakes, by natural phenomena, but he never mentions it. But well, he's one of the great geographers of all time, isn't he, Aristotle? And if he never mentions it, and he's obviously aware of Plato's thought, the implication of that would be that he, like a lot of those first, that audience, recognized this as a wonderful political literary
人们绝对似乎理解了他在用这个做什么，所以这很迷人，所以亚里士多德，柏拉图的学生，与柏拉图一起作为希腊哲学的两大泰斗之一，他从未提过亚特兰蒂斯，尽管亚里士多德对政体以及地震等自然现象都极为着迷，但他从未提过它，但是，嗯，他是史上最伟大的地理学家之一，不是吗，亚里士多德？如果他从未提过它，并且他显然知道柏拉图的思想，那么其含义就是，他和许多最初的受众一样，将其视为一种绝妙的政治文学
conceit rather than as a statement of historical geographical fact yeah so i think i think aristotle silent he's the dog that doesn't bark in the night right um and basically right the way through into the roman period people who you think might be interested in it don't mention it right so seneca who is the um the tutor of nero ends up having to commit suicide after being embroiled in a plot um he was fascinated by the idea that it might be possible to island hop um to a new world right um so he writes about it in in philosophical dramas he writes about it in actual dramas um but he he never mentions Atlantis. And even Pliny the Elder, who is very much a friend of the show, very prone to believing all kinds of nonsense.
构思，而不是历史地理事实的陈述，是的，所以我觉得亚里士多德的沉默，他就是夜里没有叫的狗，对吧，呃，基本上，一直延续到罗马时期，你认为可能对此感兴趣的人却没有提及它，对吧，所以塞内卡，他是尼禄的导师，在卷入一场阴谋后最终不得不自杀，他曾对通过跳岛去往一个新世界的想法着迷，对吧，所以他在哲学戏剧中写到了这一点，他在实际戏剧中写到了这一点，但他从未提及亚特兰蒂斯，甚至老普林尼，他非常支持这个节目，极易相信各种无稽之谈，
He does refer to Atlantis, but he says, basically, if we can trust Plato. So he's putting in that caveat. So I think if Pliny the Elder… So that suggests that pliny doesn't recognize it as a political metaphor no but he does recognize it as probably nonsense yeah basically yeah i mean it's too good a story for pliny to miss out but he's kind of saying yeah probably plato made it up right it's still quite fun so i'll put it in um and it's really only only towards the end of the classical period, so deep into late antiquity, do you get someone who's wholeheartedly a fan of the whole story of Atlantis. And this is a philosopher who's a student of Plato, absolutely devoted to him, called Proclus, who's writing in the 5th century AD. And he's all over the idea that Atlantis is true. But even he, you see, there's a fascinating passage where he kind of recognizes the parallels between the Persian invasion of Greece and Plato's
他的确提到了亚特兰蒂斯，但他基本上说，如果我们能相信柏拉图的话，所以他加上了这样一个保留条件，所以我想如果老普林尼……所以这表明普林尼没有将其视为政治隐喻，不，但他确实认为它可能是无稽之谈，是的，基本上是这样，我的意思是，这个故事太精彩了，普林尼不会错过，但他有点像是说，是的，可能柏拉图是编造的，对吧，不过还是挺好玩的，所以我就把它写进去，而实际上，直到古典时期接近尾声，也就是深深进入晚期古代，你才会遇到一个全心全意成为亚特兰蒂斯整个故事粉丝的人，这就是一位哲学家，他是柏拉图的学生，对柏拉图忠心耿耿，名叫普罗克洛斯，生活在公元5世纪，他完全赞同亚特兰蒂斯是真的这个观点，但即使是他，你看，有一个迷人的段落，他某种程度上认识到了波斯人入侵希腊与柏拉图
story of the Atlanteans invading Europe and Asia from the so uh he he says that i mean he explicitly compares the persian invasion force set out against the greeks from the um from the east and the uh the atlanteans came from the west um and and so this is example of the perfect patterns that history creates he says right not recognizing that in fact it's a perfect pattern created by plato um so he's right he's he's obviously writing in Greek. He's in the Eastern half of the Roman empire. The Western half by this point has collapsed. And increasingly over the course of the early middle ages, contacts with the Greek speaking half are lost. And although Timaeus is I, almost the only dialogue that's translated into Latin. So the only
关于亚特兰蒂斯人从某地入侵欧洲和亚洲的故事之间的平行性，所以呃，他说了——我的意思是，他明确地将从东方出发对希腊人发起进攻的波斯入侵部队与从西方来的亚特兰蒂斯人进行了比较，呃，所以这是历史创造的完美模式的例子，他说，对吧，却没有认识到事实上这是柏拉图创造的完美模式，所以他——他显然是用希腊语写作的，他在罗马帝国的东半部，西半部此时已经崩溃，随着早中世纪的进程，与讲希腊语的半部的联系逐渐丧失，尽管《蒂迈欧篇》几乎是被翻译成拉丁语的唯一的对话录，所以拉丁基督教世界的人们所拥有的柏拉图的唯一的
text by Plato that people in Latin Christendom have, the rest of the dialogues are lost. And it's not until the 15th century, the Renaissance, that Plato's dialogues come to be rediscovered. So the idea of Atlantis just vanishes, does it, effectively? Pretty much, I think. I mean, because there are mentions of it in Pliny, people know about to be rediscovered so the idea of atlantis just vanishes does it effectively pretty much i think i mean it's because there are mentions of it in pliny people know about it but it's it's not a kind of overwhelming obsession and i think that that you know what a really fascinating piece of evidence for that is the guy we've just done four episodes on christopher columbus who i don't think mentioned really mentions it at all.
文本，其余的对话录都失传了，直到15世纪的文艺复兴时期，柏拉图的对话录才被重新发现，所以亚特兰蒂斯的概念就这样消失了吗，实际上？差不多吧，我想，我的意思是，因为普林尼中提到了它，人们知道它被重新发现了，所以亚特兰蒂斯的概念就这样消失了吗，实际上？差不多吧，我想，我的意思是，因为普林尼中提到了它，人们知道它，但它并不是一种压倒性的痴迷，我认为，关于这一点的一个真正迷人的证据，就是我们刚刚做了四集节目的那个家伙，克里斯托弗·哥伦布，我觉得他几乎完全没有提到它。
No. When I think back, because we did some stuff, didn't we, about how Columbus, he went to the monastery of La Rabida and he read Toscanelli and various other authorities, sort of late 15th century authorities, and Marco Polo and Pliny, Ptolemy, Claudius Ptolemy. But actually Atlantis has never met Brazil. There's an idea of an island called Brazil.
没有，当我想起过去，因为我们做了一些关于哥伦布的内容，不是吗，关于他如何去拉比达修道院，他阅读了托斯卡内利和其他各种权威，大约是15世纪末的权威，以及马可·波罗和普林尼、托勒密、克劳狄乌斯·托勒密，但实际上亚特兰蒂斯从未遇到过巴西，有一个关于一个叫巴西的岛屿的想法。
Yeah. But no talk of Atlantis, actually, now that I think of it. That is another dog that you have two dogs that don't bark in the night. I mean, no reason. You can have a whole kennel. Well, we've got one. So that then raises the question if you're right tom if you were right and graham hancock is not right so if you're right that this is a sort of political
是的，但没有提到亚特兰蒂斯，实际上，现在我想想，那是另一条狗，你有两条夜里没有叫的狗，我的意思是，没理由，你可以拥有一个狗舍，好吧，我们有一条了，这就引出了一个问题，如果你是对的，汤姆，如果你是对的，而格雷厄姆·汉考克是不对的，所以如果你是对的，这是一种政治
metaphor um very much sort of generated by the peculiar circumstances of Athens, what, the turn of the, what is it, the 4th century BC? So the 5th, 4th century BC. Then that raises the question, why on earth did Atlantis revive in recent centuries? And is it to do with European colonialism? Is it to do with the rise of science or scientific racism? Is it, you know, what explains our appetite for, I don't want to use the word pseudo-history
隐喻，很大程度上是由雅典的特殊环境所产生的，什么，转折点，公元前4世纪是什么时候？所以是公元前5、4世纪，这就引发了一个问题，为什么亚特兰蒂斯会在最近几个世纪死灰复燃？这与欧洲殖民主义有关吗？这与科学或科学种族主义的兴起有关吗？这与，你知道的，是什么解释了我们对——我不想用伪历史这个词，
because people who love this stuff get very offended by that. So Graham Hancock is outraged if somebody calls him a pseudo-historian or a pseudo-archaeologist. But there is a kind of fascinating story here about how this comes to assume this enormous – is it about our own sense of our own hubris and our own – you know, the consequences of industrialization or something? Well, I think that one of the things that very clearly happens is that the Atlanteans, who in Plato's account are the villains,
因为喜欢这些东西的人对此感到非常被冒犯，所以如果有人称格雷厄姆·汉考克为伪历史学家或伪考古学家，他会非常愤怒，但这里有一个引人入胜的故事，关于这如何开始承担起这种巨大的——这是否关乎我们自身对自负的感知以及我们自己的——你知道的，工业化的后果之类的事情？嗯，我认为非常明显发生的一件事情是，在柏拉图的叙述中作为反派的亚特兰蒂斯人，
they actually come really to be the heroes. So that passage from Graham Hancock that you read at the beginning, I mean, these are people from Atlantis are going around trying to resurrect civilization. So that's definitely one of the things that happens. And there are various other elements. The shining ones, Tom.
他们实际上真的变成了英雄，所以你开头读的那段格雷厄姆·汉考克的话，我的意思是，这些来自亚特兰蒂斯的人到处试图复活文明，所以这绝对是发生的事情之一，还有各种其他元素，发光者，汤姆。
Yeah, the shining ones. I think, I mean, I think the appeal of it fundamentally is that it's a brilliant story. Well. I mean, it's a brilliant story and Plato. I mean, it's a brilliant story. And Plato tells it fantastically well. But it gets riffed upon in all kinds of really, really intriguing ways. Yeah.
是的，发光者，我想，我的意思是，我认为它从根本上的吸引力在于它是一个精彩的故事，好吧，我的意思是，这是一个精彩的故事，柏拉图，我的意思是，这是一个精彩的故事，柏拉图讲得棒极了，但它以各种真正引人入胜的方式被即兴发挥，是的，
And I think that we should talk about that in our next episode. Brilliant. Well, that will be something to look forward to. Tom, you talk about dogs not barking in the night. I think it's fair to say that in this episode, I have been very much Dr. Watson, and you have been an excellent, excellent Sherlock Holmes. Now, if listeners want to uncover the mysteries right away,
我想我们应该在下一集中讨论这一点，太棒了，嗯，那将是值得期待的事情，汤姆，你谈到夜里没有叫的狗，我觉得可以说在这一集里，我非常像华生医生，而你是一位极好、极好的歇洛克·福尔摩斯，现在，如果听众想马上揭开谜团，
they don't have to wait, do they? Because they can, with one click on the Apple Podcast app, they can join up to the Restless History Club or they can go to restlesshistorypod.com. There's no mystery about that, Tom. No. But if they love suspense for whatever perverted reason, they can wait till Thursday to get the truth about Atlantis.
他们不必等待，对吧？因为他们可以在苹果播客应用上点击一下，加入“历史其余部分俱乐部”，或者访问 restlesshistorypod.com，这没什么神秘的，汤姆，没有，但如果出于某种变态的原因他们喜欢悬念，他们可以等到周四来获取关于亚特兰蒂斯的真相。
And just to enhance the sense of suspense. Although I don't believe in Atlantis. Yeah. And so therefore I don't actually believe in the kind of the central thrust of Graham Hancock's thesis. I do think that in certain intriguing ways, he is onto something. Oh, I cannot wait to find out what you're going to say. I'm going to say he's totally wrong. If I wasn't doing this podcast, I would already have signed up through Apple.
为了增强悬念感，虽然我不相信亚特兰蒂斯，是的，因此我实际上不相信格雷厄姆·汉考克论点的核心主旨，但我确实认为，在某些引人入胜的方面，他确实切中了要害，哦，我迫不及待地想知道你要说什么了，我要说他完全错了，如果我不是在做这个播客，我早就通过苹果注册了，
So the rest is history because I'd be so keen to hear the ways in which you think Graham Hancock is not entirely wrong. So on that bombshell, we will see you all next time. Goodbye. Bye bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest isistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
所以历史其余部分是因为我会非常渴望听到你认为格雷厄姆·汉考克并非完全错误的那些方式，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次再见，再见，拜拜，感谢收听历史其余部分，获取额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，即 restishistorypod.com，这就是 restishistorypod.com，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的，我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，即 therestisentertainment.com，本集暂无评论，点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。